[Música]
han escuchado a alguien de pronto decir
que trabajar con mujeres es muy difícil
será por el ego que tenemos detrás
ya más de tres años escuchando y viendo
como muchas mujeres habían formado
grupos de apoyo a otras mujeres querían
darle crecimiento personal empoderarlas
y que juntas pudiéramos más
hoy en día me da tristeza ver que muchos
de esos grupos no hubieran podido surgir
de la manera que a mí me ha gustado
este tema obviamente por ser mujer me
apasiona mucho pero también por mis
vivencias y mis fracasos y que me
hubiera gustado pertenecer a un grupo de
estos en este momento
un día estaba en mi cama acostada
y pensaba que no sabía qué era lo que
pasaba
aunque estos grupos de apoyo son muy
importantes y ayudan a tantas mujeres
sentí algo en mi corazón no sabía qué
era
ese día que estaba acostada de un
momento a otro me llegó una idea la
cabeza ya sabía que era tenía que unir a
todas esas mujeres que habían trabajado
con otras mujeres que pudieran ser
coherentes y lo más importante que
pudieran dejar el ego atrás
y acorde con día
quizá ayudar unas mujeres que
pertenecían a un grupo y las líderes de
ellas fueron y me buscaron y me dijeron
que si quería ayudarlas a ellas primero
tenía que ayudar a las líderes
ese día yo no entendía qué pasaba por la
cabeza de ellas
hoy en día entiendo que era el ego el
que estaba hablando por ellas me daba
pánico simplemente llevar a cabo esta
idea
trabajar con mujeres líderes todas
empoderadas todas reconocidas y además
que ya hubieran trabajado con otras
mujeres
sin embargo tome acción y lo hice las
empecé a buscar las empecé a llamar y
leer lo que más anhelaba era poder
llevar a cabo esta unión
porque siempre he pensado que trabajando
sola
voy a llegar más rápido pero que si
trabajamos unidas vamos a llegar más
lejos
en que vaca loca me había metido todos
dijeron que sí sin titubear sin
preguntar sin decirme nada además no
sabíamos ni para dónde íbamos y todo
nació en un almuerzo
y aquí les quiero preguntar saben
ustedes cuál es la característica de las
mujeres que los hombres más critican
el producto lo pueden estar pensando de
pronto algunos de ustedes ya el pasado
es que supuestamente nosotras las
mujeres hablamos 20 mil veces más que
ellos ustedes imaginan ese almuerzo todo
es hablando al mismo tiempo una locura
pero una locura bacán y sima porque
sabía que había tocado fibras
ese día
me dio pánico
luego pánico de solamente trabajar con
estas mujeres líderes cada una dando su
punto de vista queriendo que las cosas
se hicieran a su manera en fin
pero la diferencia con estas mujeres es
que se puede llegar a acuerdos porque la
meta a la larga es la misma es ayudar a
otras
ese día nació momento
un movimiento a nivel mundial
lo queríamos traer a colombia empezando
por cal y momento es amor pasión
solidaridad sobre habilidad que
significa hermandad entre mujeres
experiencia servicio y tantas cosas que
no puedo describir con palabras pero si
les puedo decir lo que significa momento
es mujer tu momento es hoy
momento es mujer tu momento es hoy
y empezó el día a día la preparación de
ese primer evento la mejora de los
tiempos las ocupaciones de las
prioridades en fin empezó a verse que la
tarea no iba a ser tan fácil porque hay
un personaje en el cuento que quiere
gobernar todo el tiempo que se llama
pero me empezó a dar más miedo
pensar que se llegó podría ser más
grande y más fuerte que nosotros no
hubiéramos podido llevar momento a
nuestra ciudad
le voy a dar un ejemplo donde esté guau
somos sus narices si no la cobró bien
cara
y vamos a organizar el primer evento
teníamos que llegar al auditorio donde
iba a hacer
teníamos que ensayar cada una de las
presentaciones y coordinar todos los
tiempos todas dijeron si yo voy y
adivinen que ese día muy pocas llegaron
y si les digo la verdad solamente una
ensayo de verdad
y obviamente qué pasó el día del evento
los tiempos se estudiaron descoordinados
nos teníamos que demorar ocho minutos y
las que ensayaron así lo hicieron pero
las demás no terminamos 10 todos y hasta
15 minutos
este celular mío iba a estallar joy
eslava que alguien la pare porque está
hablando de eso que no sé qué
y yo simplemente me reía porque era el
ego es que nos volvía a hablar
y todo esto trae consecuencias
tres personas no pudieron seguir más con
nosotros sus ocupaciones y sus
prioridades a las cuales les doy las
gracias por el haber estado ahí con
nosotros y aunque el evo nos había
hablado al final todo salió bien en ese
evento más de 350 mujeres que estuvieron
ahí sellaron lo más bonito de cada uno
de nosotros sellaron todo nuestro amor
las ganas de servir de manera
incondicional
hoy en día somos nueve mujeres líderes
imparables inseparables hemos aprendido
que al ego hay que darle la espalda
pero no le damos importancia porque
tenemos un peso encima muy fuerte que
nos dice el pilas sea coherente
y aunque el ego siempre va a estar entre
las relaciones entre mujeres tenemos que
decirnos siempre que si se puede que los
miedos
son mentales que las barreras son
mentales que a veces aunque tengas
miedos en ese momento tienes que seguir
y que unidas podemos más
hoy en día después de seis meses en tan
solo seis meses hemos tocado a más de
mil mujeres que nos han dado las gracias
por haber cambiado sus vidas porque han
tomado decisiones
porque han emprendido porque han
entendido que si se puede y porque lo
más importante se han dicho que hoy se
quieren más que ayer
y el ego siempre va a estar ahí
pero en nuestro amor y las ganas de
servir de manera incondicional es mucho
más fuerte que él y obviamente nosotras
nos decimos siempre cuando se asoma por
ahí
y ahora para finalizar
les quiero decir
qué tal vez y de pronto tal vez
si no pasara nada entre nosotras
seguramente estaríamos dejando de ser
mujeres muchas gracias
[Aplausos]